j'ai tourné pas mal en afrique en
afrique du sud
à djibouti et jamais en clignant je
trouve ça magnifique
si tu vois pas ça c'est même pas la
peine de venir au kenya parfait coupé
connaissez le gabon et j'étais jamais
venu au kenya l'image va être assez
impressionnant
plus important c'est d'éviter la
déshydratation j'adore c'est pour aider
ces machins l'afrique est difficile pour
tourner parce que c'est la paire très
chaud très froid le soir c'est très loin
il faut grimper beaucoup tu étais un
petit peu plus difficile pour travailler
dans ces géniales pour le film parce que
c'est ça exactement comme isabelle vi
reçoit les lieux touristiques sont
nettement moins fréquentées
qu'aujourd'hui
comme elle est pas trés aventurière les
odeurs qu'on peut avoir fax en dodon
nairobi
c'est quelque chose qui sont pas
forcément super agréable pour isabelle
en ce moment là parce qu'elle
s'attendait pas à ça du refus du tout
bonne viande
j'adore ça je vous laisse là il a deux
chèvres j'avais l'impression qu'on
maintient son émotion
allez allez pop up until she entre
nouvelle et je trouvais vraiment le
personnage correspondait un mois et le
personnage de danny était parfait pour
la première fois de ma carrière d'acteur
où je suis dans une scène où on tourne
avec les massaï et où je n'ai pas réussi
à jouer les premières prises tellement
j'étais spectateur de ce que je voyais
c'est tellement impressionné j'étais
dedans
le masaï c'est magnifique c'est sûr que
c'est vous c'est tellement différente de
nous
je pensais ce qui va faire aussi la
qualité du film c'est que on tourne en
scope et qu'on est dans des endroits
absolument ahurissant c'est rien d'autre
qu'un gros chatons du wahhabisme à
l'image vaut la peine
la deuxième solution c'est de faire le
mort est d'attendre qu'ils s'en aillent
vous avez tout le monde